In a moment I will ask you a puzzle and it's a
pretty hard puzzle actually. But before I do,
I want to lead with a spoiler, which is the fact
that the way we're going to solve this involves
the use of complex numbers. And once you hear
it you will agree that that seems absurd given
that the puzzle is going to be purely a discrete
question. It only asks about whole numbers and
their sums, there's not a whiff of the imaginary
or even continuity anywhere on the horizon.
It's certainly not the only time that complex
numbers are unreasonably useful for discrete
math to borrow a phrase. The more famous example
that I could bring up would be how the modern way
that mathematicians understand prime numbers, you
know questions about how they're distributed their
density at certain regions things like that, well
it involves studying specially designed functions
whose inputs and outputs are complex numbers.
Some of you may know that this is what the famous
Riemann hypothesis is all about. Basically there's
a specially designed function and, on the face of
it, it looks unrelated to the discrete world of
primes – it's smooth, it's complex valued. But
under the hood it encodes all of the information
that you could ever want about those discrete
prime numbers and, most importantly, certain
questions about primes are easier to answer
by analyzing this function than they would be
by directly analyzing the primes themselves.
Of course our puzzle, which I promise
I'll share in just a moment, is a lot
more innocent than the Riemann hypothesis;
it's a toy problem. But at the end of the
video I'll share how the techniques that we use
to solve it, the real reason that we're here,
are actually pretty similar in spirit to the
setup that leads to the riemann hypothesis
and the prime number theorem and that
whole circle of thoughts around it.
Our puzzle for today comes from this book here
by Titu Andreescu and Zuming Feng. It's basically
a collection of problems used in training the
USA team for the international math olympiad.
And if we turn to chapter 2 advanced problems,
problem number 10 asks this seemingly innocent
question “find the number of subsets of the set
one up to two thousand, the sum of whose elements
is divisible by five”. Okay, so that might take
a little bit of a moment to parse. For example,
something like the set three one four, that would
be a subset, all of its elements are also elements
in the big set. And its sum, three plus one plus
four, is eight so that wouldn't be considered,
that's not in our count. Whereas something
like the set two three five, also a subset,
has a sum of ten that is divisible by five so it's
one that we want to count. The preview animation
that I had at the start is essentially a brute
force program trying to answer this question. It
will iterate through all of the different possible
subsets finding the sum of each one along the way
and it increments a counter each time that it
finds a multiple of five. And, you know what,
a nice warm-up question here would be to pause
and think about how many total subsets are there
overall, forget this multiple of five stuff. How
long will it take for this program to terminate?
Many of you may know the answer is 2 to the power
2,000. The basic idea there is that when you're
constructing a subset you have 2,000 different
binary choices you can make. Do you include an
element? or do not? and all of those choices are
independent of each other so the total number of
choices you have in constructing a subset is 2
times 2 times 2 times 2 on and on 2,000 times.
And, thinking about our program, that is a
monstrously huge number. So even if we gave
this brute-forcing approach all the time in the
universe, with all the physical resources the
universe could conceivably provide, it wouldn't
even come close, it wouldn't scratch the surface.
Obviously we have to be a lot cleverer than
that and if you were to just guess what the
answer should be make a rough approximation
you'd probably guess you know it should be
around a fifth of all the total subsets. There's
probably a roughly even distribution of all these
sums mod five and yes that is true that's a decent
approximation but the heart of the question the
real challenge here is to get a precise answer.
This can't be the actual answer since it's not
an integer, but is the true answer a little
bit more or a little bit less or maybe it's
a lot more or a lot less. What tactics could
you possibly use to figure out that error?
To be clear, this lesson is definitely much
more about the journey than the destination.
Will you ever need to filter and count subsets in
this way? Almost certainly not, I wouldn't expect
so, but toy problem or not it is a legitimately
challenging question and navigating that challenge
develops skills that are relevant to other
sorts of challenging questions. For you and me,
there are at least two very surprising and very
beautiful twists and turns that the solution I'd
like to share with you takes. I've already tipped
my hand that complex numbers will make a surprise
appearance, but before we even get to that there
is another strange turn which is arguably even
weirder and even more unexpected. To set the
stage though, let's just get our bearings with
the puzzle and do what all good problem solvers
should do and start with a simpler example,
maybe just trying it with the set one two three
four five. IOf you were solving this problem
with pencil and paper, you know you're
one of these kids training for the IMO,
it's not a bad idea to simply list out all two to
the five subset, it's only 32, it's not that many.
There's different ways that you might want
to organize all of these in your mind,
but since the thing that we care about is
their sum, the natural thing to do would be
to go through all of them one by one and compute
those sums. Over here, just doing it on youtube,
I've got a computer so I'll cheat a little and
show what all their sums are. I'll also cheat a
little bit and rearrange all of these, organizing
them suggestively into collections that all have
the same sum. For instance, there are three
distinct subsets that add up to six and they'll
all sit in this little box and the three subsets
adding up to 10 will all live in this little box.
And all in all the ones that we care about,
the subsets with a sum divisible by five,
have been put over here on the left and it looks
like there's a total of eight of them. Oh and,
by the way, I should say we are counting the
empty set; we consider its sum to be zero and
we consider that to be a multiple of five. By
the end, I hope you'll agree all of those are
abundantly natural choices to make. Take a
moment to compare this answer to what you
might expect heuristically. Out of all 32 total
subsets, a fifth of that would have been 6.4,
so at least in the small example the true answer
is a little bit bigger than that. That's maybe
something you want to tuck in the back of your
mind. Okay and this is the part of the video
where I'll be honest with you, I've no idea how
to motivate it personally. I like it when math
feels like something you could have discovered
yourself and if you and I were sitting down
together solving this problem, I think there's
all sorts of natural steps that you might take.
Maybe you try to understand if there's some sort
of structure to the subsets or you play around
with how these sums are distributed mod 5 at many
different iterations for other small examples and
from that maybe you try to eke out some kind
of proof by induction. When I shared an early
version of this lesson with some patrons, people
brought up some nice linear algebra approaches.
All those are well and good, nothing wrong with
those, but instead my goal here is to teach you
about something called a generating function and
it's one of those tactics where after the fact
you can think, okay, yeah I get that this works
but how on earth would you have thought of that?
Honestly, I don't know. There's a time in your
life before you understand generating functions
and a time after and I can't think of anything
that connects them other than a leap of faith.
I'm going to ask you to consider the polynomial 1
plus x times 1 plus x squared times 1 plus x cubed
times 1 plus x to the fourth times 1 plus x to the
fifth. Now I know you could rightfully ask where
does this come from? What do polynomials have
to do with things? What is the variable x even
supposed to represent right now? And essentially
x is purely a symbol, the only reason that we've
written a polynomial here is that the act
of algebraically expanding it is going to
completely mirror the act of constructing subsets
and importantly this grouping that we want, where
subsets with the same sum are all bunched together
kind of happens automatically when you do this
and let me show you what I mean. When you expand
out this expression basically comes down to
making five binary choices: which term from each
parenthetical do you choose? If you choose the
one from each of those parentheticals, that will
correspond to the empty set where we don't choose
any of the elements. Whereas, if I choose the x to
the one term and then ones from everything else,
that will correspond to the singleton set
that just contains the number one. Similarly,
if I choose the x squared term, but ones from
everything else, that corresponds to the set just
containing two. Just choosing the x cubed term
corresponds to the set just containing the number
three. But, interestingly, notice what happens if
I choose the x to the one term and the x squared
term and then ones from everything else. This
corresponds to the choice of the subset that has
one and two and nothing from everything else, but
in the polynomial, the way it expands looks like x
cubed. So we have two different x cubed terms each
of which came from a subset whose sum was three.
And, honestly, the pattern that I'm going for here
is one that's probably easiest if you just take
the time to pause and think through for yourself
what happens when you expand everything here.
Essentially every possible subset corresponds
to one of the terms in this expansion
and then the critical point is that the exponent
in the term that you get from that expansion
equals the sum of that corresponding subset.
Kind of confusing when you say it out loud,
but again if you just kind of think it through
yourself I think you can see what I mean.
For example, when all of the dust
settles and we collect all 32 terms here,
three of those terms are x to the tenth and
each of those came from a choice of elements
whose sum was equal to ten. Now normally when
we write a polynomial, we collect together all
like terms so instead of having three copies of
x to the tenth we would just see the coefficient
3 in front of x to the 10th. So each of these
coefficients is a way of encoding the number
of subsets with a particular sum. So this, like
I said at the start, is an example of something
called a generating function where the idea is if
you have some question with an answer associated
with each positive integer. So, in our case,
how many subsets add up to a particular value?
When you construct a polynomial whose coefficients
correspond to the answers to that question, you
can get a surprising amount of insight from your
original question by mathematically manipulating
and analyzing the properties of this polynomial.
There are tons and tons of examples of generating
functions, but just to bring up one other one,
which is especially fun, you can use the same idea
to study fibonacci numbers so all the coefficients
of this polynomial will be fibonacci numbers. And,
in this case, it's an infinite polynomial so
I should really be calling it a power series.
I won't fully explain the details here but I
will leave them up on the screen for anyone who's
curious. The basic idea is that the rule that's
used to define fibonacci numbers, each one being
the sum of the previous two, can be expressed
as an equation in terms of this function.
That equation, in turn, lets you write that
function in an alternate form and then,
and here's most of the details i'm skipping over,
if you manipulate that you know throw in a little
partial fraction decomposition here, a little
bit of geometric series power expansion there,
you can get yourself an exact closed form
expression for each individual fibonacci number,
which is really cool. I mentioned this really
just to show the tip of the iceberg of the
fact that this idea of a generating function
goes way way beyond our particular example.
Now, in our particular problem, if we extend
from the simple example with just one two
three four five to the big example with all the
numbers up to two thousand, our corresponding
generating function involves these two thousand
different binomial terms, you know… one plus x,
one plus x squared on and on up to one plus x
to the two thousand. And the idea is that if you
were to expand this the coefficients tell us all
the information we want. Now it would be insane
to actually expand it but it is helpful to keep
in the back of your mind in principle what that
would look like. For example, in principle if you
expanded it, you would find that the coefficient
in front of the x to the 25th term happens to be
142 and this corresponds to the fact that there
are 142 distinct subsets that have a sum of 25.
So the art of analyzing a generating function here
will be to deduce facts about these coefficients
without actually expanding the expression.
So, moving forward, I'm just going to write this
expansion more abstractly – just a sum from n
equals 0 up to capital n, where c sub n tells
us the coefficients that we don't know. All of
that starts off as a black box to us. And, moving
forward, we're going to start treating this as an
actual function, something where we plug in x we
see what the output is and then we ask what does
that tell us about the coefficients? For example,
a very easy input would be to plug in something
like x equals 0. In that case, importantly, we
know how to evaluate it using the factored form
above. If you plug in x equals 0 for everything,
all of the terms look like 1 so the answer is 1.
And, in the expanded form, all of those terms
involving an x will get killed, they go to 0,
leaving us just with the first term c sub 0. Now,
in this case, that doesn't really tell us anything
all that exciting, it essentially translates to
saying there is a single empty set, but we're
just getting our feet wet. As the next example,
take a moment to think about evaluating f at one.
This is something we can do with the expression
we know, when you plug in one for all of these x's
every term looks like a two, so in total we get
two multiplied by itself two thousand times.
On the other hand, in the expanded
expression if you plug in x equals one,
all of these powers of x go to 1, so we're
essentially adding up all of the coefficients.
Which is pretty cool when you think about
it, just by evaluating the function at a
single number we can deduce what the
sum of all of the coefficients are.
Now, again, in our particular example
it's not all that exciting, because
we already know what the sum of these coefficients
are. Remember each coefficient counts how many
subsets have a certain sum and so when you add
them up we're just counting all of the subsets
which we know to be two to the two thousand.
However, I can give you a genuinely new fact
if I ask you to evaluate this function at negative
1, take a moment to think about what that means.
If you plug in negative 1, again we start with
the thing we know, the factored expression up top,
and here all you need is to look at
the first term when you plug in x
the first parenthetical goes to zero, so the
whole expression has to be zero, but what does
that tell you when we apply it to the expanded
expression using all of the coefficients? And,
in the spirit of being as suggestive as possible
of the strange turns that this solution takes,
I want you to really visualize the various
powers of negative one in this expression
in terms of rotations. The first term, negative
one to the zero, is just one which we'll picture
as a vector from zero to one. Then negative one
to the first power is just negative one itself
which I want you to be thinking about as a
180 degree rotation away from that last term.
Then when we take negative one squared, that's
positive one, again a 180 degree rotation and
in general each successive term here looks like
another rotation by 180 degrees. Algebraically,
what this translates to is that we have an
oscillating sum between the even coefficients and
the odd coefficients, but keep the visual in the
back of your mind. This expression is true for any
generating function, but again for our special
generating function we know that this value,
this alternating sum, should equal zero. And a
way you can interpret that is that it's telling
you there's an equal balance between the
even coefficients and the odd coefficients.
And, remember, maybe in the context of our smaller
example these coefficients are encoding for
us facts about subsets, so if there's an equal
balance between all those even coefficients and
the odd coefficients it's telling you that half of
all the subsets have an even sum and half of them
have an odd sum. That's probably what you would
expect, but it's not obvious at first how you
would show that and with the generating function
it just kind of pops right out. And, again, to
be suggestive of where we're going, let me rewrite
this a little bit by taking the last two things we
evaluated, add up those two and then divide by
one half. If you think about it, this is a way
of filtering out all of the even coefficients and
killing all of the odd coefficients. So it becomes
an especially clean way to write the fact that the
sum of all of the even coefficients, which again
in the back of your mind means the total number of
subsets with an even sum, will look like half of
the total. This is, needless to say, tantalizingly
close to the actual question we want to answer;
what we would like to do is find some clever thing
that we can do to the function f some well-chosen
numbers to evaluate it on so that we get all the
coefficients corresponding to multiples of five.
Again, thinking back to what these coefficients
encode for us, that will be answering our final
question that will be counting the total number
of subsets whose sum is divisible by five.
The trick to doing this is to generalize what we
just did, where the successive powers of the input
were rotating back and forth, but this time
we don't want them to rotate every other time
we'd like them to somehow rotate with a period
of five and to do that we extend into the complex
plane. You see up there we can find a value
so that as we take successive powers of it
it will rotate by a fifth of a turn, giving us a
process with a frequency of five. And, if you step
back, I know that it's kind of absurd that I'm
asking you to think about complex numbers, I mean
we started with a counting question. It's discrete
math, but hopefully it's not all that wild.
And again, the reason that I'm drawing things
out to tee up the various strange turns in the
solution is that they're actually not all that
strange in the broader scheme of math. The trick
we're about to apply has a heavy resemblance to
many other instances of using complex numbers
to better understand discrete questions of
integers, so the more it feels like something
that you could have discovered yourself the more
it might actually be the case that when you're
working on some future problem in this circle
of thoughts you will discover it yourself.
To be specific, the complex number that I
care about is one that I'm going to label
zeta and it sits a fifth of a turn around the
unit circle. So its angle is two pi fifths radians
and its magnitude is one. This means with the
standard Euler's formula notation we would write
that number explicitly as e to the power 2 pi i
divided by 5. If you're not as comfortable with
that notation you could think of it as something
whose real part is the cosine of 72 degrees,
72 being a fifth of a full turn, and the
imaginary part is the sine of 72 degrees.
But, to be honest, you don't actually
need to think about the explicit value.
Instead, the important thing to focus on is
the property that powers of this number have.
For example, when you square it, because its
magnitude was one the magnitude of its square
is also one, but it rotates a fifth of a turn
around the unit circle so it now sits two-fifths
of a turn around. Similarly, when you raise it to
the third power you end up three-fifths of a turn
around, raise it to the fourth power you end up
four-fifths of a turn and raise it to the fifth
power and you've gotten all the way back around
to one; it's the same thing as if you had raised
it to the zeroth power, we get this cycling every
five terms, that's the thing that we care about.
These numbers have a special name, they're called
the fifth roots of unity, essentially because
they solve the equation z to the fifth equals
one, they are fifth roots of the number one.
If you just presented someone with this equation
they would probably say the answer is clearly z
equals one, but the idea is that there are four
other answers in the complex plane. Four other
numbers where when you raise them to the fifth you
get one and considering them as a collective is
often quite useful. Remember that equation,
it'll come back for us a little bit later.
So in analogy with what we did earlier where
we added together f of one and f of negative
one to get this cancellation among the odd terms,
what we're going to do is evaluate f at all five
of these numbers and then add them together and
hopefully we get some cancellation. That might
seem kind of complicated, but let's just take a
super simple example like the case where f of x
is simply equal to x. In that case, when we add up
these five terms we're just adding up the roots of
unity themselves: zeta to the zero plus zeta to
the one on and on up to zeta to the fourth. When
you add complex numbers, uh, you can think of it
like vector addition with the tip to the tail.
So zeta to the zero plus zeta will look like this
and then, if I add on zeta squared bringing the
tail of that vector to the tip of the last
one we get this. Then, similarly, if I bring
the tail of zeta cubed over to the tip of that
one and then do likewise for zeta to the fourth
you'll see how the overall sum actually loops
back to be zero. Another way to think about
this is that all five of these terms are
evenly balanced around the number zero;
their center of mass is at the origin. Now it's
helpful to think about a slightly less trivial
example, if f of x was x squared. So when you
square zeta to the zero it stays zeta to the zero.
This is just a fancy way of saying the number one.
When you square zeta you get zeta squared itself,
so you might imagine this dot up here moving
over to the zeta squared dot when we do it.
Theta squared moves to zeta to the fourth, so you
might imagine this dot moving over to zeta to the
fourth. Theta cubed moves to zeta to the sixthm,
which because we loop around every five times,
is the same thing as zeta to the
one. So this dot will move up here.
And finally zeta to the fourth squares to give
us theta to the eighth which reduces to be the
same as zeta cubed, which I might draw like this.
That might seem a little confusing to think about,
especially with all the arrows I have drawn here,
but it's worth thinking through at least once in
your life, because the idea here is that when we
square this I go to all of these different terms
and I program them to double the angle that they
have, the overall effect is to just shuffle those
terms. We get the same numbers but written in a
different order, so their sum is still going to be
zero. Similarly, if you go through this exercise
with x cubed, which I encourage you to do,
and you follow around where are each
one of these dots going to end up,
you'll be able to see that when we cube
these terms, when we take each one and we
multiply the angle that it has by three again, we
just shuffle them around same terms listed in a
different order. Unsurprisingly, the same thing
happens if our function was x to the fourth,
but critically where things change is if
we consider the function x to the fifth.
In that case, when you raise zeta to the fifth
power, by definition it goes to one. Similarly,
zeta squared raised to the fifth power goes to
one. All of these go to one, they are the roots of
unity. This is, after all, their whole purpose in
life. So in this case, when we apply the function
and add them all up instead of going to zero and
getting cancellation we get a kind of constructive
interference. All of them equal one so their sum
is equal to five. So if you step back and think
about what all those examples mean, essentially
this expression is something that will go to zero
for powers of x which are not divisible by five,
but it goes to something non-zero for powers of x
which are divisible by 5 and that's exactly
the kind of filter that we're looking for.
If you're worried that our actual function is
much more complicated than a simple power of x,
essentially things play really nicely here
because everything is linear. If f is some massive
polynomial and we want to evaluate this big sum
you could sort of think of going column by column,
where each time you really are just adding up
powers of zeta and in most cases all those powers
cancel out with each other and you get zero,
but when all of those powers are multiples of
five they constructively interfere and instead
you get five times whatever the corresponding
coefficient is. Deep in the weeds it's easy
to forget why we're here in the first place,
but remember each one of those coefficients tells
us how many subsets add up to a certain value
and so what we want is to add up all of
the coefficients that are multiples of five
and what we have right now is a way to explicitly
do that. If we evaluate this function on these
five different routes of unity which I know seems
kind of weird, then all we have to do is divide by
five and it gives us the sum that we want. That's
really cool if you ask me. We have a question
that's just about subsets, it's a discrete math
problem, and yet the way that we can answer it is
to evaluate a crazy polynomial on some judiciously
chosen complex numbers. The more math you do the
less crazy that seems because complex numbers
have this bizarre relationship with discrete math,
but it really is wonderful there's no two
ways about it. However, some of you might
complain that the only way that this is useful is
if we can actually evaluate this wild expression
on our polynomial. Now, remember, the form of the
polynomial we know the one we're comfortable with
is the factored form where you have this one plus
x one plus x squared on and on all the way up to
one plus x to the two thousand. Everything up
to this point is just meaningless symbolic play
pushing around one hard problem into another
unless we can actually roll up our sleeves
and do some honest calculation here. This is
the final thrust in our argument so step back,
take a deep breath. It's actually not as bad as
you might think, but let's start just by thinking
about how you might evaluate just one of the
roots of unity that we need, maybe zeta itself.
So what that looks like is one plus zeta times
one plus zeta squared times one plus a to cubed
on and on except, importantly, after those first
five terms everything starts repeating, because
powers of zeta repeat the entire expression up to
2000 is basically just going to be a copy of this
expression 400 times. It still might seem hard to
evaluate this expression, but it's way easier than
multiplying out 2,000 different terms. A way
you might visualize this is that we're taking
each one of those roots of unity but basically
adding one, we're shifting them all to the right.
This picture actually lends itself to a really
nice geometric intuition for the numerical answer
that we might expect. The thing that we want
is the product of these five different complex
numbers, these five yellow dots and if you know
a thing or two about complex numbers since these
come in conjugate pairs all we really need is to
multiply the lengths of these five yellow lines.
For example, that dot furthest to the right
corresponds to one plus zeta to the fifth,
which in the diagram I'm labeling as zeta to
the zero plus one, but it doesn't matter in
either case they're both just fancy ways
of writing the number two. Next to that,
we have the values one plus zeta and one plus
zeta to the fourth, both of which have the same
magnitude. The lengths of these lines are the same
and let's just give that a name L1. So we need to
multiply two different copies of that length L1
squared. Similarly, the remaining two values theta
squared plus one and zeta cubed plus one, they
also have the same length and they're a conjugate
pair so let's just call that length L2. So our
product needs to include two copies of that L2.
If we were just making a loose heuristic guess
you might notice that L1 is a length that's
something a little bit longer than one and L2
is something a little bit shorter than one,
so the final answer here probably comes to
something around two ish. We're not positive,
but something in that ballpark. To turn
this into an exact answer we could just
expand out the full expression. It's honestly
not that bad there's only 32 different terms.
Okay, you've hung with me for a long time
now, and I know that it's getting to be a lot.
But there's one final trick in this
whole argument that makes our last step
much simpler than you might think it should be.
And let's just recap to remind ourselves of
where we are. We started with this question
asking us to count the number of subsets of 1 up
to 2 000 whose sum is divisible by five. We then
constructed this polynomial whose coefficients
tell us how many subsets have a particular sum for
each value n. So what we want is to add up every
fifth coefficient of that polynomial. Then we
saw how evaluating this polynomial as a function
on all of the fifth roots of unity, then adding
them up, ends up giving us exactly this filter
that we want. And here we're evaluating just
one of those terms, f(zeta), which essentially
comes down to a product of five complex numbers.
As a super slick way to actually evaluate that
product, here's the final trick. Remember,
I described these numbers as “roots of unity,”
they solve the equation z to the fifth equals one.
Another way to think about that is
that they are roots of the polynomial
z to the fifth minus one. Now what that
means is we can factor the polynomial z
to the fifth minus one to look like this,
where there's one factor corresponding to
each one of the roots; you take
z minus each one of the roots.
This expression is kind of magical when you think
about all of the crazy cancellations that has to
happen when you expand it all out, but it is
true, and it's super useful for us right now,
because the expression on the right-hand side
looks almost identical to the thing we need to
evaluate up at the top here. It basically just has
minus signs where we wish there were plus signs.
The trick is to plug in z equals negative one. If
you do that, you essentially have the negative of
what we want, so if you multiply it by negative
one, notice how the left-hand side here, which
started out as negative one minus one,
or negative two, that just becomes two.
And then the right-hand side turns into
the thing that we want to evaluate.
So just as our geometric intuition
earlier might have suggested,
not only is the answer around two, the answer
quite magically turns out to be precisely two.
That is actually super nice, and very lovely,
because it means this bigger expression that
we want to evaluate, where we're adding up
f on all of the different roots of unity,
we know its value on the first root of
unity. It will be 2 to the power 400.
Essentially identical reasoning shows that its
value on the next three roots of unity is also
2 to the power 400. Because remember, when you
take powers of zeta squared, or zeta cubed,
you get the same list of numbers, they're
just shuffled in a different order.
The only one that's different is when we evaluate
it at zeta to the zero’th. But zeta to the zero’th
is a fancy way of saying the number one,
and we know how to evaluate this at one,
that's one of the easy things. We did this
earlier. All of these parentheticals turn
into two, so it looks like taking two
multiplied by itself two thousand times.
And so finally with that, we have a
highly explicit honest answer to our
counting question. To add up all of these
coefficients which are divisible by five,
which remember is a way of counting how many
total subsets have a sum divisible by five,
the answer is one-fifth of this weird complex
expression, which we just computed to be two to
the two thousand, plus four different
copies of two to the four hundred.
And here you might want to do just a quick
sanity check on does this answer make any sense.
For example, if you do it in the
smaller case with the set {1, 2,
3, 4, 5} and you walk through all
the same reasoning that we just did,
it tells you that the answer is one-fifth of
two to the fifth, the total number of subsets,
plus four times two to the one, in this
case, which is a fifth of 32 plus 8, which
is 8. And if you'll remember when we explicitly
looked at them all that was in fact the answer.
Look, this is a hard puzzle, and when it's worth
putting in the time to solve a hard problem
it's also worth taking some time to reflect on it.
What do you get out of this? What's the takeaway?
You could reflect on the answer itself,
how the dominant part is indeed one-fifth
of all the total subsets like we might have
guessed, and how this error term came about
from the not-quite-destructive interference
in a massive combination of roots of unity.
But again what makes this question
interesting is not the answer,
it's the way that we solved it. Namely, taking a
discrete sequence that we want to understand and
treating it as the coefficients on a polynomial,
then evaluating that polynomial on complex values.
Both of those steps are probably highly
unexpected at the outset. But both of those
steps relate to some very general and powerful
techniques that you'll find elsewhere in math.
For example, at the top of the lesson, I
promised that the technique that we would use
would be similar in spirit to
the way that primes are studied,
and the set of ideas that leads up to the
Riemann hypothesis and things like that.
Now, this is a very beautiful topic, enough
so that I think it seems a little criminal to
cram some kind of rushed version into the
end here. The right thing to do, I think,
is to just make that video I promised a while
back about the zeta function. Take the time,
do it right. But if you're curious, and if you'll
allow me to throw some things up on the screen
without explaining them, here's the two or three
sentence version of how the two are parallel.
Just like our subsets puzzle, the way that
Riemann studied primes involved a discrete
sequence we want to understand, something
carrying information about prime numbers,
and then considering a function whose
coefficients are the terms in that sequence.
In that case, it's not quite a polynomial,
instead, it's a related structure known as a
Dirichlet series (or Dir-ick-ley series, depending
on who you ask) but it's the same essential idea.
Then, the way to suss out information about
those coefficients comes from studying how
this function behaves with, you guessed
it, complex-valued inputs. The techniques
in his case get a lot more sophisticated, after
all, Riemann was a pioneer in complex analysis.
But the fact remains, extending your
domain beyond real numbers like this
offers you, the mathematician, a lot more power
in making deductions about the coefficients.
For some viewers, this all might
leave the lingering question of
why exactly complex numbers are so
unreasonably useful in this way.
It's a hard question to answer exactly, but if you
think about our puzzle, everything we just did,
as soon as we were in this situation where
plugging in different inputs revealed hidden
information about the coefficients, it's sort
of like, the more inputs you can work with the
better. So you might as well open yourself up to
a richer space of numbers, like the complex plane.
But there is a more specific intuition
that I want you to come away with here.
In our puzzle, the relevant fact that we
wanted, the sum of every fifth coefficient,
was a kind of frequency question. And
the real reason that complex numbers,
as opposed to some other structure, proved to
be useful for us is that we could find a value
so that successive products have this cycling
behavior. this use of values on the unit circle,
and roots of unity, in particular, to suss out
frequency information is extremely fruitful.
It’s almost impossible to
overstate how helpful that idea is.
Just to give one out of thousands of examples,
in the 1990s Peter Shor found a way for quantum
computers to factor large numbers way,
way faster than classical computers can.
And if you go in and you look at the details of
how what we now call “Shor's algorithm” works,
the idea is essentially this, the use of roots of
unity to detect a kind of frequency information.
More generally, this is the core idea
that underlies Fourier transforms,
and Fourier series, and the infinite
swell of topics that follow from those.
As to the topic of generating functions
themselves, we've really only just scratched
the surface here, and if you want to learn more
I highly recommend this (kind of hilariously
named) book generatingfunctionology by Herbert
Wilf. I'll also leave up a few fun puzzles on
the screen here for anyone who wants to
flex their muscles a bit with the idea.